[Music]
your whole family's here right yeah
except for my wife but your kids are
here and it clearly yeah my mom and my
mom and my babies
I noticed that they did want to take a
picture with one certain star who's that
Chris Pratt oh yeah absolutely
around the planets because he's it yeah
they're LEGO fans yeah yeah so what do
they get to walk the floor and is there
any shot that you could ever take them
down on the floor it was really cool
when I did Stargate before anyone knew I
was gonna be on circuit I got to walk
the floor and I'm a comic fan and it was
like I remember walking and going this
is the last time be able to do this it's
so much fun permission to come aboard
did you know before this that yeah I
couldn't swim no he's admitting it to
the world now might well be yeah yeah
for sure but yeah we knew we're gonna
have to swim there's no way you could
film the things we need to film
underwater
Nicole's your mom your daughter-in-law
is on big little lies too is there a
chance that you could get on big little
lies that'd be awesome I don't see that
in the near future but that would be
great for us like another season after
this season you sneak in you never know
it could be good the last thing creating
this universe and some of the it's a
very diverse universe even though it's
underwater yeah why what makes it great
about being so diverse what is the magic
I mean I mean our world is diverse
why wouldn't under the world be you know
under the sea
[Applause]
you